very often the things that we do as we
do on behalf of security all right and
people looking at through you're kind of
fixated on security or you're squeezing
my liberty because you're your focus so
much on security but in reality and this
is really the way we look at it bill if
we feel feral if we fail in the security
function your liberties at risk because
you know what this nation does after
catastrophic failure electrum we things
along those lines well that is what
would happen seriously I think the
election will hinge on whether there's
another terrorist attack in this country
I think if there is especially close to
the election it is president Trump it is
one absolute wildcard absolutely right
it is and what calls several years ago
three days before the Spanish election a
terrorist attack turned that one under
eye down of course and and you know
America is known to his pants what
what do you think about a president
Trump and or any of these Republicans
and some of the stuff they say that
strikes me as crazy I would be
incredibly concerned if a president
Trump governed in a way that was
consistent with the language that
candidate Trump expressed during the
campaign
well we're gonna do waterboarding and a
whole lot more because they deserve it
yeah you know look we did we did darling
the terrorists families oh my god let me
give you up I mean that never even
occurred to you right I mean yeah god no
yeah and you're a real badass era
general we do of course let me give you
a punch line all right if he were to
order that once in government the
American armed forces would refuse to
act what oh well that's that's quite a
statement sir I thought the whole thing
was we you have to follow orders you
cannot you are not committed you so
required in fact you required not to
follow an unlawful order that would be
in violation of all the international
laws of armed conflict Wow so you've
given us a great reason not to support
Trump it would there would be a coup in
this country
okay I know coup but they just I mean
I'm serious no I think I think it's a
coup that you said it good luck with the
book thank you